so this is just absolutely fascinating
you may remember this democratic
congresswoman former democratic
congresswoman named tulsi gabbard who
really um
had a faction of the left like two two
percent basically um two percent of the
left was absolutely enamored with her
and she would use terms like regime
change and endless wars
in order to
sort of um convince people i guess that
she was like maybe on the left but the
truth was much of what she said was
always reactionary and since leaving
congress after her completely failed
presidential bid
uh she's really become a darling of the
right appearing regularly on fox news
she's going to be speaking at cpac which
we'll get to a little bit later and this
is almost beyond parody tulsi appeared
last night with sean hannity
and her take on the russia ukraine
situation was so outrageous so unhinged
so unabashedly pro-russia
that propagandist sean hannity had to
pump the brakes and say hey hold on a
second
putin has had these
territorial ambitions for a very long
time here it's not
just about security tulsi appearing and
saying oh what putin's doing is that
he's protecting russia
what he's doing is for their security
and hannity has to be like listen
putin's had these these territorial
ambitions for a long time and says
ukraine's not even a country
um when hannity makes more sense than
tulsi you know she's nuts take a look at
this ending the world that we live in
and not the world that maybe some people
wished existed and that reality is putin
has made very clear all along
that uh their security and his mind uh
is what's at stake here and they do not
want to interrupt
ukraine is not a country
and he has been saying this going back
many many years so this has been these
territorial ambitions have existed
security component
they they have they go way back and they
they pre-exist this i love what he says
i want to focus on the security
component right because that's the
component that's that's interesting to
you
she is so unhinged that hannity has to
say hey tulsi that there's kind of like
other realities here that you're not
living in
and i'm going to try to pull you back
towards them like hannity's saying
your pro-russian propaganda is a bit too
much
this is when a friend would be like
tulsi you might want to sit this one out
when hannity has to slow you down
and of course it is is once again a
reminder of all the people that got
bamboozled by by gabbard into thinking
she's uh she's some kind of uh she's
speaking truth to power or she's she's
on the left she's a true progressive the
last real liberal or whatever and it's
it listen uh hillary clinton's not
likable
and it's very popular to dislike hillary
clinton but when hillary said
maybe russians are grooming tulsi for a
third party run i i don't think hillary
was literally correct but hillary's
instincts about tulsi were completely
right i mean it is at at the end of the
day i actually wonder
does tulsi believe this stuff or does
she just want attention is this a
character that she's playing you know we
we've speculated that
candace owens for example
is not really this ignorant right-wing
loon that it's more of a character she's
developed for for profit uh we've
wondered did 40 year old then 40 year
old dave rubin
really go from being a bernie supporter
to a trump supporter through some kind
of genuine political awakening or was it
because of the money that came attached
with saying i've quit being on the left
i don't know i don't know if tulsi
believes this stuff or or is just saying
it because it's developing this
profitable character for her i don't
even know if it's profitable but what i
can tell you for sure
is that when hannity is slowing down
your pro putin propaganda and you're
supposedly on the left you've really got
to be evaluating um
sort of like what positions you're
staking out here and unfortunately
there are people who have sort of woken
up to the the scam of tulsi gabbard of
that two percent of the left that fell
for her
maybe one percent you know half of it
has woken up and is like oh my god that
was really really bad and i've seen some
people publicly even apologize for it
but some people are still
falling for it and if you want to see
examples of it go to my twitter dpakman
look at my post about tulsi uh speaking
at cpac and then just read the comments
read the comments and you'll see the
degree to which people are still
unhinged here and have completely fallen
for it really going mask off here and i
mean
good job i guess to sean hannity for
shutting it down
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video